so i'm here with dr mahadevan from
stanford university but we're not going
to talk about medicine we're going to
talk about something that at least i
think is equally fascinating and that's
his name so so what is your full name
full name is swaminatha venkatesen
mahadevan
and my full name is salman amin khan and
the reason why this is fascinating other
than the fact that that dr mahdivin's
name takes up many letters uh the reason
why it's fascinating is that
in in in south india names aren't the
way that we associate it so so my name
for example which is a non-western name
but it has the same structure as a
western name i have a last name and this
is the same last name that my father had
and my father's father had and then my
parents came up with the salman and the
amin and this so this part is unique to
me and that this is my this is my family
name and so that's that's how i'm named
in north india and that's how western
people are also named but but what is
what's going on here
well the only actually unique part of my
name is actually my last name mahadevan
that is actually my name so this is so
your your father's last name is not
mahadevan no
my father's unique part of his name
is venkatesen so what was your what was
your father's name my father's name just
to confuse you is mahadeva mahadeva but
that that wasn't because of this no
that's because his grandfather's name is
mahadeva okay so let me write so his
name is mahadeva mahadeva swaminatha
swaminatha
swaminatha
venkatesan venkatesen so let me let you
let me do that same purple color so that
we can track the venkatason so
swaminatha
swaminatha
venkatesen
venka
tayson exactly so his
so this was the unique
oh this is confusing
wait you explain it to me all right so
when we look at his name the only unique
part of it his name is his last name
menka tayson right his middle name is
his father's name is his father's unique
part of his name exactly so his father
his father had the swaminatha exactly
so i mean not your grandfather my
grandfather the swaminatha up here right
i see so it kind of moves its way
forward exact generation generation
exactly so it became your father's
middle name correct and then it's now
your
it's now your first name it's my first
name and both of my brother's first name
as well and both of your brother's first
name and all of your father's
brothers and sisters middle name uh he
only has two brothers but their middle
names are also swaminatha fascinating
fascinating so your name essentially
kind of tells you exactly who your
grandfather and father correct correct
but then you lose you lose the names
beyond that so for example in my name
khan i there's i would imagine there's
some guy
you know 300 years ago maybe with the
last name khan genghis
perhaps
about 900 years ago but but or a
thousand years ago but uh but i don't
know hopefully well who knows
he's a mixed bag but yes but potentially
potentially yes right but you wouldn't
get that with with this with your naming
scheme you would lose that information
it makes it very difficult unless
somebody knew where you lived and knew
your family for many years with each
subsequent generation you can see that
that name moves and then gets dropped
and so become very difficult to to trace
someone back in fact if i was trying to
trace my genealogy if i just went by my
last name alone they i would find other
mahadevans but they would be unlikely
that they were related to me right
that's like me finding other sals
exactly likely over there so so it's
interesting so when people call you dr
mahadevan it's like calling me i'm not a
doctor my mother would like me to be but
it's like calling me dr salman exactly
and when when people refer to me the
unique part of my name my nickname is
maha
because the other two portions of my
name are my grandfather's name and my
father's name right so it's really just
completely uh complete well i guess it's
not completely reversed because to some
degree this is now this is kind of what
you would consider what we what a north
indian or a westerner would consider
their last name
in terms of it's shared with your
parents and with your siblings exactly
exactly and this is kind of like a
middle name that you got from your
grandfather exactly kind of exactly
fascinating so is are you continuing
with this with your children
unfortunately the the trend has stopped
with me so all of us in my family except
for my wife
okay have the last name mahadevan okay
uh my son has the same middle name as me
thank a tayson to honor my dad and my i
actually for my daughter his middle name
is named after my wife's father
venkateshwaran right i see i see so but
so now a thousand years in the future
people know that they are descendant of
the doctor
we'll see